how does it I can tell you that we had a
giant read-through with all the cast in
October and I think pretty much
everybody cried at one point everybody
really good news the producers during
the commentaries for season seven
specifically talked about season eight
scenes specific to Cersei Lannister is
character so I'll play that clip then
I'll explain what it is that they're
teasing for season eight so just another
reminder that it's always important to
listen to the DVD commentaries because
they do talk about what's happening next
season there are no visual effect shots
in the sequence but this scene was shot
in the paint Hall in Belfast in our
illustrious set in the map room that
they were about to walk down into Danny
David asked us to make it an exterior
location in an upcoming episode but I
can't tell you why but that'll pay off
to the Courtyard always was thought of
as being a an exterior courtyard before
she had the map painted you know
hence the sunlight it used to be at
least the story
taller but there was a need to see this
guy in this coverage forthcoming Chris
you've had that map painted in your
living room they copied the one in my
liver we've actually had the map now
painted on the shores but it's it's on a
big picture in the office have you seen
that no haven't seen it coming up the
stairs yeah but because of this
commentary and because of information
that HBO's released publicly we have an
idea for the stuff that they were
teasing that they would be paying off
for Cersei like a scene that they would
be paying off during season eight so no
worries no spoilers I'll just be talking
about stuff that they
release publicly but yes spoilers for
season seven stuff obviously what
they're saying is is that they designed
this floor map specifically to be an
outdoor set meaning that it's like the
godswood at Winterfell is that you can
see the sky when you're standing it
you're not covered by anything so why
was Cersei need to be able to see the
sky well I think it's important for a
couple reasons but the obvious one and
not the one that I think they were
talking about was just a visual metaphor
of snow falling on the map the entire
map of Westeros like at the end of
season seven the moment that snow hits
it is the same moment that the night
king brings down the ball so they closed
down the season with a nice metaphor
winter is officially here is on
you're all screwed but what I actually
think they're talking about when they
say you know we're gonna be paying
something off the fact that this is open
air is really this Cersei is going to be
able to see the Dragons flying overhead
because they've been talking about
episodes they've been filming and
Dubrovnik recently with Cersei she even
has like a new costume the silver
epaulets of season seven on her costume
are now gold you can make all the
valonqar jokes that you want gold will
be their shrouds because we know Kit
Harington and Emilio Clark are there and
there's no big crazy battles happening
and David Nutter is directing the
episodes that are not supposed to be the
big crazy battles episodes one two and
four it would be really weird for Jon
and Daenerys to fly down to King's
Landing to meet with Cersei before the
big battle with the night king the
second big Battle of Winterfell that
they've also been filming separately at
a different location the moment that
they're going to pay off for Cersei
probably comes in Episode four which is
also a very important episode because of
where it falls between the big battles
in the actual finale remember there are
only six episodes and because Dan and
Dave are directing the series finale and
they're not known as like their big
battle of directors that's Miguel
subhanak there is probably not much of a
big final battle in the actual series
finale if there's gonna be a big final
battle that's probably going to be
episode 5 you might just spill into the
beginning of episode 6 episode 6 was
probably just aftermath and dealing with
what they do to rebuild the kingdom
anybody that isn't dead after episode 5
working in Reverse if there's gonna be a
meeting between John Daenerys and Cersei
it's probably going to be in episode 4
so that's probably
we're seeing happen here because if
there was an actual big battle happening
there would be hundreds and hundreds of
extras that they'd be filming and this
is a completely different scene but
regardless of what they're filming right
now just remember they don't film in
chronological order they group things
together just based on how they can
schedule all the actors and if there's
like a really big battle it gets extra
nuts but you'll probably continue to see
like little small moments between a
couple different main actors then the
really big crazy battle stuff which is
kind of spoilery so I won't post that
stuff here but you can imagine there's
gonna be two really big battles one at
Winterfell in one of King's Landing
towards the end of the season but just
to talk a little bit more about Cersei
during season eight Jaime's said this
really important line at the end of
season seven where he basically gave her
two options both of which were terrible
and it was all because of her
backstabbing Jon Snow and Daenerys oh
we're not going to be sending any help
for them now the monsters can't each
other while they battle in the north we
take back the lands that belong to us
and then what then we in the fighting in
the north is over someone wins you
understand that don't you
if the dead win they must south and kill
us all if the living win and we've
betrayed them they march south so either
way sir she's kind of screwed but you
kind of have to laugh at the way she
deals with stuff like this so it doesn't
really tell you whether or not they're
successful and beating the night king in
what seems like it's going to be the
Episode three battle for Winterfell the
second battle for Winterfell but because
of Daenerys his vision the snow and the
ruins of King's Landing in the Iron
Throne a lot of people are just
wondering if that's actually going to
become a reality in the night King will
bring Vissarion down and just destroy
parts of King's Landing or maybe if
that's destruction that happens during
the final battle between the army and
the north Jon Snow and Daenerys US
forces in Cersei and King's Landing
because regardless of which dragons do
this damage I do think that it's going
to come to pass and remember that it is
snowing in King's Landing so that
explains why it's snowing here like even
though people wonder if the night King
brings winter with him he can create a
storm but relatively quickly it's gonna
look like this in King's Landing no
matter what just because of normal
snowfall I've done a couple videos about
why I think that their positioning
circe to be the true villain of the
final season just because it's easier to
connect with her and understand where
her head spaces at you've never heard
the night King speak you kind of know
what he wants but that's only because of
things that George R Martin has implied
in the TV show has kind of got an off
book and he still hasn't introduced a
night King in the books there is no
character like that unless we meet one
during book six so if you heard people
complain about like the big CG villains
in movies in the past year like rings of
garbage in the sky type villains that's
what the night King is slowly turning
into so that's why I don't think that he
will ultimately be the final villain I
think that will be Cersei they'll have
their big final battle then they'll deal
with the aftermath in Episode six but I
know a lot of you been asking for
specific death predictions and
characters there are certain characters
that I'm a hundred percent are going to
die there are a lot that I'm on the
fence about right now I'm waiting until
they finish filming to do more videos
about that because you do get a lot of
clues from actors doing interviews and I
do think that we're gonna see a
comic-con trailer because they'll be
done filming by the beginning of the
summer comic-con is at the end of July
so they will have some footage to show
off and they'll be back on their normal
hype schedule if you remember the
earlier seasons they would start
dropping teasers towards the end of the
year they would really ramp up in
January in February then boom they
dropped the season in April that's
probably what's going to happen for
season eight so for everybody that's
bummed out that there are no new
episodes this year they will actually be
dropping new footage we probably just
won't see it till the third and fourth
quarter of the year but let me know in
the comments what do you think comes
before that big final battle Jon Snow
with Daenerys try to meet with Cersei
maybe they try to make a deal with her
and she brushes them off and that leads
to something worse or do you think that
the night king is successful in
destroying Winterfell marches South Jon
Snow and Daenerys then try to fly to
Cersei to try and get help before the
army gets to King's Landing
and destroys everyone either way it does
seem like that final battle will be
happening at the Red Keep and it makes
sense because they're the two most
important locations on the show you go
back to the pilot episode you have
Winterfell then you have the red keep in
the iron throne the thing that we've
been talking about for the past eight
years
there is a new round of that DVD
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video congratulations to the winner
from my last game of Thrones video
Donnie Williams please
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to watch Tyrion and
George are Martin talk about the end of
Game of Thrones and click here to learn
more about the secrets of Winterfell
thank you so much for watching
everybody's day awesome I'll see you
guys tonight